perhaps one did not want to be loved so
much
as to be understood
[Music]
who controls the past controls the
future
who controls the present
controls the past
in a time of deceit
telling the truth is a revolutionary act
all animals are equal
but some animals are more equal than
others
war is peace
freedom is slavery
ignorance is strength
every generation imagines itself to be
more intelligent than the one that went
before it
and wiser than the one that comes after
it
the best books are those that tell you
what you know already
the creatures outside looked from pig to
man
and from man to pig
and from pig to man again
but already it was impossible to say
which was which
but if thought corrupts language
language can also corrupt thought
if you want a picture of the future
imagine a boot stamping on a human face
forever
doublethink means the power of holding
two contradictory beliefs in one mind
simultaneously
and accepting both of them
if liberty means anything at all
it means the right to tell people what
they do not want to hear
political language is designed to make
lies sound truthful and murder
respectable
and to give an appearance of solidity to
pure wind
until they become conscious they will
never rebel
and until after they have rebelled
they cannot become conscious
in the face of pain
there are no heroes
power is in tearing human minds to
pieces and putting them together again
in new shapes
of your own choosing
if you love someone
you loved him
and when you had nothing else to give
you still gave him love
reality exists in the human mind
and nowhere else
freedom is the freedom to say that two
plus two
make four
if that is granted
all else follows
it's a beautiful thing
the destruction of words
[Music]
the essence of being human is that one
does not seek perfection
the choice for mankind lies between
freedom and happiness
and for the great bulk of mankind
happiness is better
orthodoxy means not thinking
not needing to think
orthodoxy
is unconsciousness
nothing was your own except the few
cubic centimeters inside your skull
four legs good
two legs bad
on the whole human beings want to be
good
but not too good and not quite all the
time
we do not merely destroy our enemies
we change them
[Music]
the only good human being
is a dead one
sanity is not statistical
confession is not betrayal
what you say or do doesn't matter
only feelings matter
men can only be happy when they do not
assume that the object of life is
happiness
one does not establish a dictatorship in
order to safeguard a revolution
one makes the revolution in order to
establish the dictatorship
all the war propaganda
all the screaming and lies and hatred
comes invariably from people who are not
fighting we know that no one ever sees
his power with the intention of
relinquishing it
there was truth
and there was untruth
and if you clung to the truth even
against the whole world
you were not mad
your worst enemy is your own nervous
system
at any moment the tension inside you
was liable to translate itself
into some visible symptom
man serves the interests of no creature
except himself
let's face it
our lives are miserable
laborious
and short
if people cannot write well they cannot
think well
and if they cannot think well
others will do their thinking for them
to see
what it is in front of one's nose
needs constant struggle
in philosophy or religion
or ethics or politics
two and two might make five but when one
was designing a gun or an aeroplane
they had to make four
if you kept the small rules
you could break the big ones
the greatest enemy of clear language is
in sincerity
every war when it comes or before it
comes
is represented not as a war
but as an act of self-defense against a
homicidal maniac
if you want to keep a secret you must
also hide it from yourself
can you not understand
that liberty is worth more than just
ribbons
we are all capable of believing things
which we know to be untrue and then
when we are finally proved wrong
impudently twisting the facts so as to
show
that we were right
we are the dead
our only true life is in the future
[Music]
man is the only creature that consumes
without producing
the consequences of every act are
included in the act itself
[Music]
a person is lying to you if he says that
he is honest with you
if there really is such a thing as
turning in one's grave
shakespeare must be getting a lot of
exercise
if both the past and the external world
exist only in the mind
and
if the mind itself is controllable
what then
it is curious how people take it for
granted that they have a right to preach
at you and pray over you as soon as your
income falls below a certain level
all men are enemies
all animals are comrades
some ideas are so stupid
that only intellectuals believe them